protests are growing in the city this
morning after a suspected bomb attack
what do you got wonder Michael Mason
outstanding warrants in four states with
fraud so let's go get up discreetly okay
this does not look good for you oh [ __ ]
it
I stole the back but I didn't know there
was a bomb in it but you ran innocent
people do not run jeweler coming after
me have you seen yourself must be really
good
I'm the best walk up to me and steal my
water still there
what's the monies time give me that
the bomb was made by an undercover
police officer your jaws to pose this
down this is my cool you want to clear
your name go in there get me a lead deal
this is an opportunity it's all about
the distraction
good job I'm work for the CIA
cities under tomato they do today we
have a conspiracy they planted another
bomb I think you got the wrong address
we're compromised they were tactical gas
masks these guys aren't cops francese
with a city right now you got a job to
do
you really should think about anger
management breyer your breakfast and
you're responsible
you can't just want to start firing
you do this you on your own dryer and
what can we do there's only two of us
what are you doing going it alone no
plan no backup I'm reckless and
irresponsible can I get a gun has he
admit I see that Nevada this is all a
massively busy pass me the house could
be the top is Neha